oui
bonjour
je suis fou
je suis ici aujourd'hui pour lui dit
l'ami justice je suis ici pour martin
joyce et chacun il peut aussi cet argent
qui ne le verra plus jamais car ce sont
les plus grands perdants temps ça je ne
veux pas que sa mort soit unies tués
combien de combien de vies humaines
poudre qu'il encore qu'en phase ou qui
seraient pas n'être que les idées
racistes systémique avec avaient nourri
la nation autochtone je suis convaincu
que ma conjointe est décidée parce que
les racistes systémique a tous
contaminés l'hôpital de joliette
tu m'as contre 8 j'ai beaucoup de
questions il ne souhaite pas eu
d'enquêté brown a lancé où on perd toute
la lumière
l'objectif est bien sûr pour obtenir
justice pour tous mais aussi un moyen de
s'assurer que ce qui est arrivé s'il
n'arrive plus jamais le père pensant
tout les autochtones surtout des femmes
qui sont victimes de raciste d'un des
hôpitaux québécoise équilibre des
situations inacceptables ma conjointe
avec amp alourdi
si l'armée populaire du camp nou ja til
doute que les situations semblables qui
ne sont pas dénoncés parce qu'on ne sait
pas pas qu'on jette à lui qui signe des
niveaux dans l'agonie entre les deux ans
et demi moore
ce kit est supposé protéger
l'immunisation télé vous dans
l'indignité tôt qu'elle avait besoin de
ça pour me retourner jusqu'à la paix
ils droit à des commentaires et plus
d'immigrants et d'une violence inouïe
qui démontre encore une fois que nous
sommes traités différemment nous les
autochtones en lui l'âme la vie d'avant
on a envie la mise devant 2007 enfants
on a lui la vie de ma conjointe joyce
elle n'est plus ici avec nous petit
souci pour lui
pour jeff bezos trépanation je vous
remercie nous ali les québécois lancée
en automne qui démontre leur soutien à
leurs familles défilent événements merci
pour tout l'amour que vous nous donnez
de votre soutien jour après jour dans
cette dure épreuve
pour m'apporter vos ports si des traces
grâce à où je me tiendrais debout pour
djeuns pour mes enfants pour ma famille
et pour ma nation et pour mon pays je
demande à mon chef
si le premier ministre m'ont pris
ministre comment changer d'institution
un peu de brume l'hymen souhaité que
tout le monde
donc
[Musique]
si son gamme so big band
j'ai fait un collègue présentement parce
que tu pas devenu comme si j'ai juste de
la tristesse
top
mais merci monsieur